what what ended up being the reason why
you had to go sit down for three and a
half years uh
so
we were still at jackets man I'll just
play it I might as well just say it
because every time I try to [__] it
explain myself it sounds terrible that I
was even with a dude that was still some
jackets like but what happened I went to
The Vape Store
I had an altercation with somebody at
the vape store yeah Fairfax but it was
like about something else it was the
manager that did something to one of my
people outside of the workplace I told
him come outside we chopping it up it
gets heated
the dude that I'm with sneaks off into
the store because everybody's [__]
not paying attention he goes into the
[__] storage room and steals like
eight Vape jackets it comes running out
knocks over a [__] uh
ladder
so it alerts everybody and then they
start fighting them and [__] and all
that and like I'm breaking up the fight
um telling them what the [__] are you
doing stealing like yeah I'm saying like
but there's no audio on the camera I'm
like yelling at him on the camera the
whole time yeah
they get off of them whatever the case
is
and uh
he ends up leaving with me so they say
that I'm a part of the crime because I
left with him but I was getting I really
was did he like own up and be like no it
was on me no no he did some oh [__] and
he told him like he got like three photo
dudes life over that [__] too not over
that robbery like him fighting that case
and trying to get himself out of it he
told on some murders Jesus
that's crazy bro this is crazy such like
a it's like one of my day one [__] I
didn't even know you had that in you my
boy is crazy as he goes it's such a
weird moment to like get caught on
camera it's just such a
it's like a flash in a pan incident
where you're like this [__] is not like
a normal dub caught a case over that
[__] that was about uh crybee death
stared up yeah that's what's my boy
that's why I call defended wow because
he picked up a jacket off the ground
because the jackets flew everywhere it
was everybody but he grabbed the jacket
but they got his license plate number
when he grabbed the jacket so they were
just like I don't know because of the
fight and the damages that were done to
the employees that ran up like they I
feel like we should have filed a lawsuit
on them because like I mean in L.A it
could have worked yeah because like are
you allowed to chase somebody out the
store and fight them over in the
inventory I know it says in the rule
book you guys probably give it up you
guys probably called the police
shoot him which is crazy but you could
yeah that's what I'm saying like I I
know the law but I was in jail so it was
no way I could yeah I mean because it's
like bro that can't be in you guys's
handbook to chase people lost prevention
handbook because it's like let them go
and call the police you're not supposed
to do anything physical
recovery yeah I mean so it is what it is
and they they wanted me to tell on these
same murders
you get what I'm saying so they bet your
boy did yeah that my boy was telling
though he was telling them on some
murder so they kept like oh your
co-defendant tell me you told us that
you know something man I don't know
nothing yeah I don't yeah I mean like so
that's why it was prolonged and covet
came around made my case stretch even
longer like you know what I'm saying and
I ended up getting out with time sir
but they charged us with robbery Jesus
so you're in were you incarcerated were
you incarcerated when it passed
what was that environment like
like how was that received in jail like
what was the the
mood like in there because man I I was
on the radio the day it was the Sunday
he passed
and I could and I had a really good
relationship with nip you know
and I couldn't even tell you man I've
never experienced anything like being in
La it's live day to day
this is his birthday yeah so it's their
day today I just I've never experienced
like Kobe died and like and listen man I
said it's here for Kobe too yeah but it
was not like when Nick died that [__]
would Kobe [__] me up too but when
Nick passed it you could like bro I've
never seen like a city heartbroken like
that the jail like I said I've never
seen they get [__] that supposed to
hate the hood they crying the enemy's
crying
everybody listen to him no matter if
they try to act hard like [__] nip at
the end of the day everybody [__] with
Nipsey yeah I mean like in his show like
the whole the south side is for sure you
know they love Nipsey yeah yeah yeah I
mean uh they was [__] up about it
everybody was [__] up like it was
crazy because I'm like
because uh op told me he like hey bro
call in to see they say nip just got
killed though Kershaw sauce and I'm like
man stop playing with me he like he like
but this my boy though I'm like why are
you why is you playing with my own boy
he like no I'm serious and then I he
like you could see like a tear trickling
down I'm like
[__] I get to the phone I'm like hey
they like yeah I'm like man what the
[__] look like he's like uh call right
back we about to tell you what happened
we gonna tell you who it was
I called back
and they tell me like they figure out
how to tell me when they tell me I'm
like
what the [__] is going on out there like
how the [__] did he where did he even
come from how did they get into it like
you know what I'm saying like that [__]
was crazy bro